on war perception we specialized in  technique to show people things they see  every day in a way that they don't  [Music]  our moto is too fast to see too cool not  a lot of times you'll see something  happen and you won't even think twice  about it because it happens so fast once  you see that slowdown or so certain ways  where you can understand what's going on  with that subject it's almost always too  cool not to see after they see it that  way you can never undo that so go back  and look at that subject again and  you'll never forget what they saw once  we take that little moment of time and  show them all the things that happen  backpacks in action  [Music]